my lords and members of the house of
commons
her majesty's government's priority
is to grow and strengthen the economy
and help ease the cost of living for
families
prince charles delivers the queen's
speech at the opening of parliament as
she misses it for the first time in 59
years due to health issues it is now
going to become more of the norm for the
for the queen not to be seen and charles
to be far more visible in a statement to
e.t on monday buckingham palace
announced queen elizabeth will miss the
event due to episodic mobility problems
and in consultation with her doctors she
reluctantly decided to not attend quote
at her majesty's request and with the
agreement of the relevant authorities
the prince of wales will read the
queen's speech on her majesty's behalf
with the duke of cambridge also in
attendance and prince charles and his
son prince william did just that with
charles delivering an 11-minute speech
with a message from his mother
her majesty's government will level up
opportunity in all parts of the country
and support more people into work
this news comes on the heels of several
cancellations from the queen lately
instead she's opted for virtual
appearances like this one at windsor
castle this all ahead of the platinum
jubilee festivities this summer which
will celebrate her 70 years on the
throne the focus is on on the queen and
the queen being you know well and
absolutely able to take part in those
celebrations this is an incredibly
important event um and one that the
queen is very keen to celebrate she's
very much looking forward to the jubilee
celebrations it turns out the queen
won't attend every upcoming jubilee
event because the palace is pacing her
now that she's 96. a family source told
et that due to mobility issues her
schedule has been scaled back but still
the monarch has a lot to look forward to
including another reunion with prince
harry and meghan markle and this time
with their two kids archie and lillabet
who will be attending the june
celebrations she hasn't met her
great-granddaughter lilly bird she
hasn't seen archie for nearly two years
now i think the queen particularly given
that she's not 100 at the moment will
have just wanted this to be a warm
encounter nothing too difficult while
prince harry megan and their little ones
will be present at the queen's birthday
parade they will not be joining the
royal family on the balcony it will be
limited to members who currently carry
out public duties you'll remember the
couple confirmed their exit as working
members of the royal family in february
of 2021. you know the queen has missed
harry i
as difficult as the last year has been
the interview of course with oprah has
has been very very hard for the queen
and for the whole royal family but there
will be lots of quality time well spent
a source close to the royal family tells
e.t the queen is delighted she will be
meeting her great-granddaughter for the
first time and she's excited to soak up
moments with archie and lily
[Music]
you